[Musique]
sans transition on parle de fabrice
l'acteur de comédie qui est toujours
activement recherché par la police
la maison encerclée de policiers au nom
mais sûrement des étudiants en
hypokhâgne déguisés pour un bizutage
sans rien oui vous êtes en hypokhâgne
aller en prison
[Rires]
grâce à sa facile oui et si j'ai mon
fils ma bataille de la boyne
[Musique]
sans transition on parle de fabrice
l'acteur de comédie qui est toujours
activement recherché par la police
[Musique]
sofia libère on est ensemble en 4e
fabrice attendent bien avoir quelque
chose oui oui plaisir incroyable
fabien fabrice
[Musique]
jean-pierre je te présente fabien sa
camarade de collège que je me croise par
hasard bah on chantait fabien maurice
moi j'ai connu un fabien mais il était
de tarbes
ça vous dit rien
non je vois pas dans un grand
nom mais si sa mère tenait une boutique
de vêtements ouais
non non je suis désolé je peux pas le
bon alors faut pas dire vous êtes de
tarbes
par exemple écouter bon je vous propose
qu'on prenne un verre ont compensé
l'ambiance qu'un peu de mal à prendre
vraiment falloir y aller